what's up reject nation I'm Greg Alba
what's your channel something called
struggle nation struggle nation we
should just change the real reject
reject nation I mean do you try I could
change my to struggling youtuber
struggle reject we are setting ourselves
up to not grow guys there's a trailer
here called Project resistance which
journey Oh a little something about
because you know you game all the time
stream all the time you get those twitch
donations sometimes those YouTube super
chats never just hot hoes being laps
keep playing like I'm not familiar with
this the sauce came out on the Resident
Evil channel you said you know a couple
of things about it I just watch check
out the trailer first let's talk about
it that sound fair yep okay if you said
no I still would have yeah I know you
were done anyway no respect from people
hey it is your place so it's right
coming to my place you treated me a
respect but I spit on your face I'm
sorry about that I have a cold
rule the rules yes and
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
SiC
[Music]
good-looking game though you know the
cinematic but they're probably like this
[Music]
[Music]
the hell it's all connected Tokyo Game
Show we'll be watching that okay okay so
project resistance nya I thought that
was really cool I don't know anything
about what we just watched is that is
that within the Resident Evil world yeah
like I don't know too much about the
store all I know is this multiplayer
that thinks up the four players and from
what I'm saying from the trailer it's
like some kind of simulation where
they're using the the moths from
President universe and going against
players and you work together to take
care of them like that's that's all at
all I'm knows based on what I've seen in
this trailer so far but it looks like it
could be promising I mean those graphics
were pretty insane yeah they did the
traditional Resident Evil's yeah
monster look the graphics are really
really good and I know it's cinematic
but the actual game will look like that
because Resident Evil 2 the remake it
looks like that was interesting about
this multiplayer element is like I
usually associate the main players and
Resident Evil to be people with a
background who have some type of
training with weapons yeah I can survive
and this looked more like a Walking Dead
type of group of service yeah like you
know regular people that you don't know
about and now there are heroes yeah you
know I don't know how it's gonna because
traditionally the the Resident Evil
games that went multiplayer weren't that
good okay like outbreak back in a day
and all that so I'm hoping and this one
is better but it seems like resin he was
on the only you know good path right now
they came up with the remake the remake
was great 7 was great so I got I got
high hopes for this one I played
Resident Evil 6 is that the one where
you can do co-op that's 5 & 6
the camera zooms out dramatically
dramatic effect dramatic effect the show
that there is no one here anymore
I like how they tell us it was a
checkpoint twice just to make sure we
realize yeah yeah I played five my
girlfriend five five was good well you
know having a girlfriend you can game
with this is already a step in the right
direction well he usually she doesn't
let me game with her usually she makes
me sit on the couch and watch her game
that's even better that mean she takes
initiative yeah but I just want to you
know take initiative with her well I
mean that's not always possible you
gotta you know gotta work up to it so
you watch her game like oh can I try it
too and then you work your way in there
the next thing you know you both playing
and then she locks me in the bathroom oh
my dad that happens to this is you know
part of being in a relationship you're
the first person and bring reassurance
to the relationship I could spend
anything let's see what see we're
dealing with here project was a I'm a
surprised yeah but the film video later
cuz well my studies messed up I'm curled
up in the ball that's the worst thing to
drink when you message something's
messed up is it yeah [ __ ] I think I
found the real project resistance and I
we can feed it the game well did you
know who the character was at the end
yeah who was it
mister mister X he's a piece of this
created hunter that they made to like
hunt down loose ends okay oh so it is
within the resident evil world itself
yeah like where everything that they
fought against their their resident evil
monsters and now they're all you know in
the story oh that's crazy to crane a
little universe here mmm-hmm awesome I
got a
for a resident evil 3 for 6 plate what
we do at 5:00 VIP Lita to the remake
brazen evil - okay and then you know
about this thanks man hopefully my guy
because we it doesn't really hurt half
of this discussion was not dedicated to
the game it up no you guys can't
subscriber the real oh wait no YouTube
question what do you guys think of the
game are you excited yeah let's nope
that's how follow hashtag extermination
on the youtubes follow the real rejects
on the youtubes click our notification
bells click mine first that one's more
important then click his afterwards
we'll see who gets the most views you
should do a reaction to this game on
your own channel and then I'm gonna have
people comment fake saw you already
covered on the real rejects now that
looks a lot it's not double mmm look the
same dude don't be racist I'm just
saying you your brother's the same why
can I have a twin brother look that
looks like dude you make a good point
before I wrap this up it's a game
trailer I gotta give a patient the day
shout-out to a very special human being
in my heart of hearts his name is Tyler
hake you love this guy Tyler is from
Wisconsin oh I own a ps4 then he
actually gave me as a gift
really yeah how did a man in return I
sent him a
photo of me sitting on the toilet that's
it I didn't want to take that photo but
part of my girlfriend's humiliation
tactics were to photograph me after I
went unconscious due to the drug she
gave me Oh
before she locked me in there as if you
took a photo and in return I'm like well
I actually look pretty good in this
photo so I sent it to Tyler as a
thank-you man when it's a win-win man
Tyler I know you're grateful for it
that's part only part of why I love you
you're just a great guy also I have a
couple of friends can't name who because
they're on the internet and they don't
want anyone know yeah we're moving to
Wisconsin so I'm gonna be paying them a
visit they're two of my closest friends
nice and when I go to Wisconsin you best
believe you're gonna see what you saw in
that photo but in real life up front
close brothers a little run some oder
run now come on man you know I look good
run right now come on you said the whole
you never watched YouTube until you
watched me and that's why I don't make
money now neither do you make great
points man they're such good points my
feelings are hurt
you